- I saw this picture.
What's going on here, man?
(audience laughing)
That is a really sexy number.
- I guess, when in Australia, yeah...
- [Kelly] You leaned in.
- But anyway, we, we spent
a day out in the harbor
and I met some very good friends there.
My friends Sharon and Hayden in Australia
and they, you know, we
planned to spend this day
on the harbor on this yacht.
And they asked me if I'd do that.
And originally I said no.
And they said, come on, come on.
I said, okay, of course.
And they said, well, we're
gonna bring a bunch of 'em.
And we hope to get everybody
in the budgie smugglers.
And they're actually, when it came time,
there was only me and another one of my,
I actually dragged some makeup
artists who agreed to do it.
John Moore, so we threw
them on, took a picture
and quickly got out of
them and covered ourselves.
(laughing)
- Wait, I have to ask
you, what did you call it?
A smuggler?
A what?
(laughing)
- Yeah, budgie smugglers,
I believe they're called.
It's like an Australian
tradition, I believe.
(Kelly laughing)
- They wear them a lot in Australia.
- Budge smugglers, banana
hammocks, they're like...
- [Kelly] The one guy in
the picture is amazing.
He's got his legs full out.
He's just, he's embracing all of it.
I love it, well, right on.